6 21 it's a monday morning and heather
look who it is
monica can you sing for us monica i
swear
by the moon and the star is in the sky
and that's it yeah mike dropped should
we let the pros do it
please let the pros
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah i know takes you back doesn't it a
whole bunch of us are flashing back to
that school dance when you were kissing
somebody in the corner and you know you
had no business doing it talking about i
swear your mama yeah she knew what was
going on anyway
that is the group all for one uh the
guys are back with the remix to the song
it's actually a parody for xbox can you
imagine i had the chance to speak with
one of the lead singers jamie jones he
was so cool about their new venture
tell me how does it feel to have songs
that have stood the test of time
over all kinds of changes in the music
industry honestly you know it's a
blessing i think that every artist wants
to have what i like to call career songs
you know songs that you know just seem
to have a life of their own that you
know parents pass down the kids sisters
passed down to brothers and you know
we've been so blessed and fortunate to
have a few songs like that you know that
here it is now you know we're
celebrating 28 years together the same
original four of us you know and and
young kids know our music and it's trip
so but it's also like i said it's a
blessing and you know we're very
thankful and grateful hey you are not
unfamiliar with las vegas you all had a
residency here back in what 2018 tell me
about it
yes so it was the i love the 90s
residency with salt and pepper and rob
bass and kid and play and involved and
mark mcgrath and us and
um it was a lot of fun and we were
hoping and praying that you know that
all the stuff going on behind the scenes
would get worked out so that we could
still be there now um but honestly like
i said it for us it was so different
because you know we're used to always
having to travel even now you know i'm
getting as soon as i get off with you i
got to get ready to roll you know and it
was crazy that here we are and
our travel was just hopping in an
elevator and going downstairs and
getting to work so
it was a lot of fun and hopefully you
know we'll be back we we love vegas and
you know we want to come back and and
hang out there with y'all a little
longer you guys are doing what a lot of
celebrities uh are doing a lot of
singers are doing lately a lot of bands
you guys are doing a lot of
collaborations but the funniest one for
me y'all done collaborated jamie with
xbox
[Music]
it was just a lot of fun i mean because
you got to remember like our generation
is the video game generation yeah yeah
grew up with all the old school games
you know and and when xbox came out i
remember being on tour and running to
the mall and waiting in line to grab one
so here it is you know however many
years later you know and they want to do
this
90s nostalgia
music video to talk about their new xbox
service you know and and um we just
happened to you know
be uh on their mind and uh so it worked
out we got a chance and that was
actually during the whole quarantine
period and yeah
i hadn't seen the guys for over a year
and we were talking and had been on zoom
calls but it was kind of just amazing to
be in the same room again and then also
to do something super cool like that
that all my you know i have three sons
so of course them and all their friends
like yo your pops is on the xbox yo
i so enjoy talking to jamie we had so
much we had so much fun with this
interview guys and when he talked about
his three boys guess what he has two in
medical school no kidding yes
i was like are you old enough to have
grown men he's like oh yeah they're
grown men all right hey you guys but uh
thank you so much uh for uh you know
joining with us and jamie if you're
watching i hope that you get a chance to
come back to vegas and you guys get a
residency because we love the 90s for
sure right guys i swear i do
i've been doing that all weekend heather
by the way hey and don't forget to catch
my moj show facebook live tonight of
course we're going to replay the
interview with jamie so you don't want
to miss that